what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
John Humphrys me I'm not tired I'm baked
out of my mind
let's get two things straight we're
gonna watch the Hitman III 2015 trailer
that's right kids we are hopping in this
so late we figured what III happen in
last week we might as well go back for
years and see what's going on or it's
another request on the hit benarjee key
always request these games cinematic
trailers and I love doing it I missed so
many of them and when we get a catch up
they're good aren't they good John
they're usually quite cinematic and
rousing and creative so on par with the
language
let it go let it go this is one Timothy
Olyphant played yeah
I could have brought that girl's ass out
more that should be gonna do that shot
you know yeah just pull some dead or
alive' beach volleyball girls
[Music]
comes as if Breaking Bad made that
outfit it's always flash to that
whoa damn
it always has Tom Perez run go
whoa whoa
see him cool you know you gotta love
this sound design on trailers I feel the
same as that way you know what with the
way the beat was going and then his
breath which is how I sound at the
beginning of sex all right at the end
I'm usually passed out okay okay yeah
it's the longest minute and a half once
a month that I experienced may wake you
up with the defibrillator and all that
stuff it's I've gotten used to it
yeah or used to be like who are you now
I'm like I get it now I know you guys so
with the sound design in this video yeah
the the then when the sound cuts out
after the gunshot at the end only hear
the music but there's no breath and then
I was thinking and the way they edited
that music made it really sound like he
was breathing heavy and then there's a
shower there's no music and it's just
him breathing you're like oh so he was
really running
yeah they're using that got nothing else
on the trip yeah
beautiful human percussion no I mean
from what all I know about hit man this
trailer actually took me by a lot of
surprised it's a cinematic trailer
obviously but like the the snow setting
threw me for a loop
this almost felt like a trailer for a
season of TV or for like the whole video
game cuz it's like here's a bunch of
different places and different settings
with a bunch of different people it
looks like something's going wrong in
each my ass it's funny because I think
this is just as good as the hit man
movies oh definitely it almost as if not
just as good let's have Hart is this two
minute and 50 second trailer is probably
better constructed the whole of the to
it man you know that said we got a it's
it's coming along and one day we'll get
that perfect hit man moving Tim if y'all
font will come back as someone who knows
literally jack about the Hitman
storyline I don't know anything about it
I can't even tell you if the movies were
remotely close how does the game the
cool thing about this what I love about
the game trailers that they've done in
the past like I don't decade or
something the way they do visual
storytelling to the Dicker's sometimes
they'll even do it for sequels where I
won't have play at the original game and
then you watch a trailer like this and
it still feels like there's something
you can latch on to here this is a very
tense situation beyond the like the
music cues I was talking about the music
kind of has like that nightclub Menace
tune you know something out of like John
wick or collateral you know one of those
kinds of robbing sinister quality that
line at the end of like good to have you
back you see that he's having a
difficult time just training like this
is this is a lot of work for him for
anyone this would be difficult right not
for rocky in rocky for
yet enough so much less oxygen up here
the person getting back into the game
that this is probably gonna be a scary
situation even for someone like himself
but also the color palette I love how
with the last shot that last shot is
perfect the way with the blue background
is in the forest but even his eyes seem
to have a little bit of the reflection
of the color that the weather is you
know that's about as deep as I'm gonna
get really pale hazel eyes to catch the
light from the snow yeah and I hear that
in there actually the first level of
this game you're actually a different
character and the whole point is you
have to go to the snowy place and
convince him to come out of retirement
he's got like a big long beard at the
beginning and stuff like that and it's
really like an 80s action movie before
it transitions into like a traditional
hitman that would be cool I know right
you just press X & Y repeatedly to
convince you know to further convince
and if you fill up the convincing bar
then it'll come out of retirement gentle
I've never played this game yeah I know
because if you fail that level then you
fail the game I've latched on have you
you get some teases adds a little bit of
plot mechanics like that can't just seem
unintentional oh you're showing us with
the dude in the Breaking Bad oh it is a
top it has existed for many years like a
hazmat suit it's just like it's not as
radioactive space outfit or just a
hazardous materials suit or RT McFly
wore it to yeah she's just breaking bad
now owns the rights they have co-opted
the imagery a thousand percent well yeah
all those billboards I'm you see how
you're like oh it's pretty well yeah in
this video when they were creating meth
in the kitchen no and they're cooking up
rapping you see that there's gonna be
some type of poisonous toxic yeah I went
around in this that is probably gonna
play a factor into it this is cool and
it's sort of inspiring in terms of like
assembling a sizzle reel or assembling a
type of trailer you know oh and you've
also got this like Fashion Show with
this you know guy at the center of it
looks like I don't know he could be some
kind of like
class person you got to take out or
maybe like a big bad mogul character or
something it seems like the lab in this
fashion show aside for more the Hitman
himself agent 47 or whatever like are
the two main things
the reason I'm noticing this
specifically for this game trailer is
you said something at the beginning of
us talking about it about how this feels
like it could be a trailer for a show
and it made me go trailers for shows
usually aren't done well like I don't
feel like trailers for shows properly
capture a season yeah they always feel a
little bit weird and I always watch the
show and I'm like oh their shows so much
better than the trailer for this I'm
like yeah to capture a whole game story
is a lot of work so thinking about what
the editors do and the fact that more
than movies and shows for game trailers
the cinematic one they often just make
stuff for the trailers yes yeah that's
what I was about to say was like maybe
with the TV show you know you're just
bound to we're not gonna shoot a bunch
of extra stuff just to make a show
trailer we're just gonna use the footage
and we had exactly for this you have
freedom to make the exact kind of teaser
you would want you know they haven't
whole from the exact right brush strokes
of the story in the gameplay and all
that stuff hello hit Bannerjee thank you
so much for sending this our way listen
I'm just gonna read the hits last
messages I haven't reply to him yet he
said hey this is your firely homosexual
buddy
from across the border the entire bit
poster reaction was golden so much off
the rails thank John for teaching me the
meaning of an anachronism that was fun
anytime living at this new place is
awesome all of my housemates are super
cool and we have become a giant
homosexual family now you guys should
definitely come here sometime soon it's
gonna be a homosexual blast I added a
couple that paraphrase or expanded Troy
thanks for always being happy I feel
like the firely homosexual thing was
something we said in his last shout out
that I'm just not remember yeah yeah
that sounds like it like a Gregory House
original or did he just open up and say
hey I'm really gay by the way super yeah
I know you opened this up and I was like
is there a whole bunch of history I
missed ya
here but he put it in quotes so I'm
assuming we made some jokes I'm pretty
sure that firely homosexual is something
like the the second you read it out loud
all of a sudden my body had a muscle
memory yeah I'm gonna have to track down
that shoutout now I've only heard a
couple people open up in a private
manner that they're firely homosexual
I'm gonna say where we were we reacting
to a trailer that had a heavy LGBTQ
slant or uh you know knowing us it
probably didn't matter
and you know just made it work anyway
some some kind of well you make sure to
hit man all the butts and bye wait
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Val I'll hit the like
button if you like videos on YouTube and
check us out in heaven find out who
makes it there after we die yeah vote
vote with your touch-tone phones